wovon träumst du in deinem leben
ich träume von einem eigenen haus mit
garten
ich träume von einer familie mit vielen
kindern
ich träume von einer langen weltreise
ich träume davon eine weltreise machen
zu können
ich träume davon erreicht zu werden
ich träume davon reich zu werden
woran denkst du
[Musik]
woran denken sie
kennen sie
ich denke an meinen letzten urlaub
ich denke an meine
hinterhalt
ich denke an meine kindheit denkt daran
die wäsche zu waschen
denkt daran die wäsche zu waschen
denkt daran die tür abzuschließen
denkt daran die wohnung zu putzen
[Musik]
denkt daran heute den karton vor die tür
zu stellen
heute den karton vor die tür zu stellen
woran erinnerst du dich woran erinnerst
du dich ich erinnere mich an nichts mehr
von gestern abend
ich erinnere mich an nichts mehr von
gestern abend
ja klar du hast zu viel getrunken
ich erinnere mich daran dass wir nach
der disco noch einen kebab gegessen
haben
nicht daran dass wir nach der disco noch
einen kebab gegessen haben
woran
sie sich gern woran erinnern sie sich
gern
ich erinnere mich gern an meine jugend
ich erinnere mich gern an meine karriere
ich erinnere mich gern an meine hochzeit
ich erinnere mich gerne an meiner
hochzeit
fürchtest du dich wovor fürchtet du dich
wovor fürchten sie sich wovor fürchten
sie sich
ich fürchte mich vor spinnen
ich fürchte mich vor hunden ich fürchte
mich vor hunden
ich fürchte mich vor dem fliegen
ich fürchte mich davor meinen job zu
verlieren
ich fürchte mich davor dass es einen
krieg geben könnte ich fürchte mich
davor dass es einen krieg geben könnte
ich fürchte mich davor zu versagen
wovor hast du angst wovor hast du angst
ich habe angst vor insekten
ich habe angst vor engen räumen
ich habe höhenangst
ich habe angst davor die prüfung nicht
zu bestehen
ich habe angst davor einen unfall zu
verursachen
wofür interessierst du dich
wo
für interessierst du dich
[Musik]
wo
für interessieren sie sich
wofür interessieren sie sich
ich interessiere mich für politik
ich interessiere mich für literatur
ich interessiere mich für sport
ich interessiere mich für sport hast du
eine frage schreibt eine frage in die
kommentare wir werden sie beantworten
hast du eine frage schreibt eine frage
in die kommentare wir werden sie
beantworten